so we tried these before delicious but  we didn't really know you were supposed  to put stuff in them there's nothing  inside so this time we're going to put  stuff in them we're probably still gonna  mess it up there's just nothing that  looks like any of these things in  America so this is like a little boat  for your food these are so cute you put  some of this stuff in it  moon beans a little bit of this tamarind  sauce  the final part is like a big old dip  from your flavored water let's get to  business  oh my god uh-huh I do get the feeling  you're supposed to take it all in one  bite  it's like crazy and good the sauces are  magical spicy sweet everything oh no I'm  sorry little pillow it's like a savory  gusher it's like filling up a pita with  something if this is the way pamper you  supposed to be eaten it's how you say it  pani puri really oh god I can't really  think of an American equivalent for this  and that's a problem America we need  Stuber who came up  [Music]